from seeming so unimportant that she was
written out of the comics to proving
herself worthy to carry the title of the
Mighty Thor and plenty of comics worthy
twists and turns over the decades in
between here's the truth behind Jane
Foster Jane Foster was introduced in
journey into mystery number 84 only a
month after Thor himself made his first
appearance in Marvel Comics while issue
number 83 had been devoted to
introducing the world to dr. Donald
Blake and his son during alter ego the
following issue took a little time to
fill out the supporting cast and it's
not tough to figure out where creators
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby drew their
inspiration if Thor was Marvel's take on
Superman then Jane Foster was Lee and
Kirby's rip on Lois Lane like her DC
counterpart she was the co-worker that
the hero was pining for who was far more
interested in the superhero than the
secret identity the only big difference
was that Jane was a nurse working with
Blake rather than a reporter and at
least in her first few appearances Jane
was a redhead rather than a brunette but
over the next few years
Jane would distinguish herself from Lois
by learning through her secret identity
and being brought into the
mythologically inspired world of Asgard
for a while at least
yeah okay you may tell that was for New
York I like her
Thor and Jane hoped to marry but if
you've read enough comics from the era
you know something had to get in the way
the major obstacle for this set of
lovebirds came in the form of Thor's
father Odin who forbade the marriage on
the grounds that Thor was an immortal
Asgardian Thunder God and Jane was human
there's a pretty simple solution of that
problem though make Jane a goddess
that's what happens in 1967 Thor number
136 where Thor takes Jane home to Asgard
to meet the family Odin in a seemingly
benevolent move makes Jane a goddess
grinning her an Asgardian costume and
the power of flight unfortunately for
Jane this gift comes with a few strings
attached she has to prove she has the
courage of an immortal to stay in Asgard
and Odin decides that the best way to
test Jane's bravery is to lock her in a
dark room with the unknown a
Lovecraftian horror that can only be
summoned by a gigantic magic tuning fork
Jane freaks out upon being confronted
with the unknown and declares her desire
to get the heck out of there with that
Odin declares her unfit strips her of
her powers and boots her back to earth
without any of her memories of Thor
she's given a job with hunky doctor
Keith Kincaid with whom she immediately
falls in love Jane made an unexpected
return to the pages of Thor in issue
number 231 from 1975 Jane
mortal as ever is on her quite literal
deathbed and can only be saved by divine
intervention in this case the role of
the divine is played by SIF the goddess
who had been romantically linked to Thor
since somewhere around the eleventh
century and returned to Thor's life
while Jane was off romancing dr. Kincaid
SIF discovers that Thor still has
feelings for Jane and when she learns
about James ailment she pulls off some
eldritch magic in issue number 236
merging her own godly essence with
Jane's mortal form seemingly sacrificing
herself in the process Jane now
recovered and with a taste for adventure
that Thor attributed to sift spirit
inhabiting her body goes back to hanging
out with the god of thunder on Asgard
and even gains the ability to transform
into Sethe just as Don Blake transformed
into Thor none of these changes lasted
all that long though eventually dr.
Kincaid started wondering where his
fiancee had gone and SIF returned to the
book as her usual God Lisa
Marvel's Thor wasn't some modern hero
inspired by the legendary Thunder God
this was literally the Norse god Thor
who lived in Asgard had been worshipped
by the Vikings thought Frost Giants
commanded lightning and had a
shape-shifting troublemaking
half-brother named Loki
and as God
and that's where I come from you just
happened to be bound to the very human
Don Blake who had more earthly concerns
and taught through some lessons about
being mortal as time went on the stories
gravitated to more epic fantastical
adventures in the realm of gods and
Giants unlike say Peter Parker whose
real-life concerns balanced out the
superheroism of spider-man Don Blake
felt more and more like an unnecessary
element of Thor comics Blake was not in
fact a real person but an identity that
Odin created to teach his son humility
so when Walt Simonson arrived to write
and draw a five-year run that would
become the definitive take of Thor in
1983 one of the first things he did was
ditch Blake entirely reasoning that he'd
outlived his purpose the stories
refocused on those fantastical
mythological elements and Thor II even
got a new secret identity in the form of
Sicard yerson a construction worker who
was literally just Thor wearing glasses
don't worry about Blake's friends at his
medical practice though in Thor number
354 Fandral the dashing dropped by to
give his nurses and staff a bag of
Asgardian gold as their severance pay
with that Thor's romantic life was
resented around SIF while Jane did
appear late in the simonson run it was
only briefly and revealed that she and
Keith Kincaid were happily married and
expecting a child after a year-long trip
to an alternate universe and back
Marvel's Fantastic Four and Avengers
books took a back-to-basics approach to
their characters in the late 1990s and
the relaunched Thor was no exception
bringing back the idea of giving the God
of Thunder immortal civilian identity in
this case Thor took over the body of
paramedic Jake Olson who just happened
to wind up working in the same hospital
as dr. Jane Foster
Thor was initially reluctant to reveal
his true identity to Jane given her life
with Keith Kincaid and their son Jimmy
which she eventually figured it out
herself when Jake slipped into the faux
Shakespearean dialect that Marvel's as
Guardians tend to use with that shiri
entered Thor's life and his stories and
floated around the Marvel Universe for
the next few years working briefly for
Tony Stark as his personal doctor and
showing up in the aftermath of Civil War
as the resident physician for the
underground Avengers things weren't
exactly great though
Jane would lose her husband and son to a
car accident which happened off panel
and she was herself diagnosed with
cancer
good news is that all of this would pave
the way for her greatest role in the
Marvel Universe yet while they would
eventually draw inspiration for more
contemporary comics such as Planet Hulk
and Civil War the earliest entries in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe drew
pretty heavily from the first few years
of Marvel Comics Iron Man for instance
brought in Pepper Potts and happy Hogan
who hadn't really been featured in the
comics for some time and Avengers
brought the team together to face down a
threat from Loki just like the originals
did in 1963 2011's Thor was no exception
in that regard and in addition to the
fantastic realms of Asgard and Jotunheim
land of the frost giants it included
Jane Foster is Thor's human love
interest Jane was played by Natalie
Portman and instead of having a medical
job she was an astrophysicist studying
cosmic phenomena
you know like rainbow bridges and stuff
science your ancestors called it magic
and you call it science well I come from
a place where they're one in the same
thing Portman's version of Jane is a key
element in blending the fantastical and
sci-fi elements that made for such a
distinct character in the Marvel
Universe in the following film the dark
world she took a trip to Asgard herself
sadly by the time we caught up with Thor
again and Ragnarok she had dumped him
probably due to Thor's insistence on
spending two years flying around in
space and decapitating fire giants
instead of spending any time on their
relationship sorry I hear that Jane
dumps you she didn't dump me you know
Joss mutual dumping after the 2014
Marvel event original sin the son of
Odin believing he was unworthy and
therefore unable to wield Mjolnir the
Marvel Universe was thoughtless but only
for a bit
the Odin son himself was of course still
agog and continued to fight against evil
wielding a magic axe named yarn Gorn but
without his hammer he wasn't great at it
his first outing ended up with him
getting his arm cut off with his own axe
fortunately someone else was around to
lift mule near and become the all-new
all-different Thor and since the new
Thor also happened to be a woman it was
actually pretty easy to tell them apart
initially the new threw his identity was
kept secret from both the readers and
son his first theory was that it was his
mother Frigga but that turned out to be
wrong eventually he discovered that this
new Thor was Jane Foster who had lifted
the hammer with the motivation that
there should always be a Thor around to
protect people her transformation also
kept her alive while her mortal form was
by all appearances dying from cancer
Jane served admirably in the role of
Thor but eventually she ran into a
pretty big problem
mangog an unstoppable monstrous creature
formed from the cloaked collected rage
the unbridled hatred of a race of
billions slaughtered by Odin in ages
past with no other way to defeat him
Jane chained man GOG to Mjolnir and
threw it into the heart of the Sun
destroying both man gog and hammer
itself robbing her of her ability to
transform with that her mortal body died
but she was soon revived by Odin and his
son now Thor once again
who channeled the gods storm that had
powered Mjolnir to resurrect her she
then focused on her treatment and her
cancer went into remission
Jane recently appeared in War of the
realms a massive marble crossover in
which all of Asgard's enemies united
under the direction of the Dark Elf
Malekith that lay siege to earth
dividing it up among themselves at the
end she briefly returned to the role of
Thor wielding a mule near from another
dimension and fighting alongside three
other versions of Thor from different
times it ended with Jane's hammer
shattering and revealing itself to be
unda yarn the all weapon a mystical
metal capable of shaping itself into
whatever weapon she needed another major
consequence of war of the realms was the
death of the Valkyries including
Brunhilde who has been known as super
hero Valkyries since she debuted in 1973
inspiring the MCU character of the same
name
when Jane visited Brunhilde in the
morgue to pay her final respects burn
Hilda spirit charged Jane with taking up
the mantle of her responsibilities Jane
agreed and took on her latest identity
as Valkyrie and continued her ascendance
as one of Marvel's most prominent
heroines in july 2019 Marvel Studios
laid out its plans for phase 4 of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe at San Diego
comic-con 2019 there were plenty of
welcome announcements in there from a
black widow solo film to the arrival of
a multiverse of madness in the sequel to
Doctor Strange but one of the most
interesting announcements came when the
next Thor movie was discussed
store 11 Thunder was an
for release in November 2021 with Tyco
ITT returning to direct after the
success of thor ragnarok chris hemsworth
will be back as Thor and Tessa Thompson
will return as Valkyrie but there's
going to be another more surprising
return after being absent for Ragnarok
and seen only in recycled footage from
the dark world when she appeared briefly
in Avengers endgame Natalie Portman is
returning to the MCU as Jane Foster and
that's not the only news it introduces
for the first time female Thor Jane will
be huffing Mjolnir herself and
presumably fighting alongside the Odin's
son and his new axe form breaker that
will make Jane only the fourth person in
the MCU to lift the hammer and
considering that the other three are
Thor Odin and Captain America that's a
very good company to be in check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the Marvel
comics are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]